and that's pretty much when i found out
that i had three testicles
oh [ __ ] i broadcasted that are we are we
live
let me increase your audio levels a
little bit
it turns out you only need two
testicles you only need i think you only
need one if your goal is procreation
if you is that tragical i always wonder
does that mean that those little guys
have to work harder or that it's just
like
oh no we don't use that side of the road
anymore i really don't know how it works
and i don't understand what happens when
a guy you made a baby though you must
know
the process why do you have two instead
of the back up
is it like a weak it's a wingman
same reason you've got two lungs two
lots of you say two kidneys yeah this
this is why i think that americans have
four hearts
americans kind of like their huge
there was a there was a [ __ ] this is
science this there was a huge boom
uh in the americas in the uk kind of uh
uh
kind of stayed at an even keel as far as
their level of procreation
because the two testicles were like
after you no after you please i know
after you no after you no please after
you not to you
and then the canadians started to drop
off because they were even worse and
americans were like get the [ __ ] out of
my way and they just
blows past you what about you i'm sorry
go ahead
[Laughter]
well here we are everyone hi
i managed to offend we're live too you
can't edit that out
we are i wouldn't edit it out anyway by
by choice we're keeping all that in so
hi everyone welcome to episode 60 of
play watch listen
not you tim tim yeah except everybody
but you just
get him out of there there is actually
not a tim in the chat
we're okay we don't have that one's good
not anymore god damn right there's not
[Laughter]
very obedient um for anyone who's
watching live i will
take this down after it's live uh anyone
who's watching dead
we miss you yeah
i will take this down i have a
three-year-old i'm being
very i'm being very respected
um i can't change anyone's audio so if
the audio is all different
there's nothing i can do about that
spamming it in chat will unfortunately
not be able to change anything clearly
you can't do anything about my audio
i can't do anything about you in general
troy he's a free agent he does something
unsolvable
um so if you do see people uh
complaining about the audio levels as
they join
the live stream please just tell them
there's nothing we can do about it or
just let them be
up to be upset and learn how to live
their lives like if that's bringing them
joy if that's how they extract pleasure
from the uh from the show is to
criticize the microphone levels then
that's i'm i'm full for it
i don't think there's a lot of people
that do though i think there's a lot of
i don't think there's a lot of people
they are they're from my camp that's for
sure i would say a lot
yeah no your audio no i'm saying my
tribe
of of audio people who are going to come
and be like
what microphone is that i don't think
it's okay i think
people know how zoom levels work not
only that but also
you but we're terrible at getting it
right you are the one guys like i don't
know it's a mic
man i don't know it's a pre i'm the gear
head
which is awesome you are much more of
your head than me but
that why that's why it's all the more
ironic when
my audio doesn't work it's true you're
set up
your setup is kind of bursting under its
own weight like
troy your audio generally doesn't
require any editing at all
mike's god love him
oh i have a creative vision for how this
audio works and i would really
appreciate everyone that call respected
that
oh i respect it but in relation to
people uh talking about
you know people jumping in the chat and
complaining about audio i'm not saying
anything that's important don't worry
where do you think backseat gaming comes
from
you know like if i'm streaming and
someone's like do this do this do this
this doesn't generally annoy me i know a
lot of people get very annoyed by it
where do you think that
mindset comes from because like i'm
usually like hey i want to figure it out
myself so i'm just not going to read
this but it doesn't piss me off like
some streamers get very annoyed about
that
people who who spam messages on the
internet about telling you how to fix
things where where do you think that
comes from with their personality
because i would never do that i i'll
i'll go last
i can tell you for me it is
really uh it tests my patience
to watch someone struggle when i know
how to help them
even if they are like let me figure it
out there's a certain element of the
personality that's just like
but yeah i know and because it's no
different than if you're in the car with
somebody and you're like
there's the turn's coming the turn's
coming the turns the turn the turn you
should start signaling
the turn is coming it's upon us this is
the moment like i i have a hard time
like it takes a lot of discipline to not
be very annoying so
anyone who drives you anywhere is
panicked the whole time because that's
your commentary the entire time
i i think that's a very philanthropic
view like that that's that's the that's
so generous
it is yeah but no i think it's a
generous way of looking i think it's
because
there is a lot in this world that the
perception is
we don't have much control over top down
would be
death government whatever you can like
just
list taxes to get death and taxes and
then yeah but everything else from there
we have control over ish
the oh epictetus would disagree but i
think that
well come at me bro bro two columns
column a column b
my thoughts my f and my uh choices that
those the two things that i can control
everything else falls in the way and
if i just i sound like jeff goldblum
just then didn't i uh
two two columns of course column a
column b oh my god in heaven
austin can you do musical compliments to
this impression
stella by starlight of course a
beautiful beautiful piano piece uh
originally written in
1945. i saw some john williams i want
some jurassic park can we get a little
[Music]
i was gonna go some jurassic park but i
was trying to remember
the howard shore score to the fly i knew
it i knew you're gonna go to the fly oh
i'm sorry that was disgusting he throws
up the donuts beautiful
um i always like the armrest like the
high back syndrome
you did mike i i feel that
uh in the same way that people take to
twitter to
um or read it or whatever to uh
sometimes very victory in a very
vitriolic way profess their
beliefs or or their opinions especially
if
there's there's a because there's a
haptic response i type it i see it and
it gets a solicits a response
there is a feeling of agency that goes
with that so i did something
if i if i typed in all caps
then somehow that demonstrated
it had some impact and i think that by
and large people
damn it predominantly speaking people
want to have
an impact and they just don't know how
to go about it and so they pick fights
on the internet
um and you should do this is me somehow
putting myself
above you into a
elevated position so i feel better about
myself
you think that's a secret well so that's
that feels like two different
things always two different ideas always
in security
go because you're basically saying i
want control
i want some dominion over life itself
but also
i want to feel above somebody else those
feel like it doesn't necessarily have to
be both those don't automatically go
hand in hand
i suspect both are possibly true and
maybe
in some people simultaneously true but
you kind of started on one point it felt
like and then you ended on a different
point do you know me
because i mean we all of us right have
lots of interactions online with
strangers every day right and i think
one thing i've definitely trained myself
to do
is to assume a lack of impulse control
in a lot of cases and kind of a
directness where someone people don't
necessarily always know how rude they're
being i guess i kind of try and give
dropping the flag on that go ahead just
just kind of
just like letting letting that kind of
let they
always re i try and read things with the
best intent like i assume if someone is
offering help
maybe they're just offering help it kind
of goes back to austin saying of like
people don't necessarily know all the
social niceties of like this is a bit
rude or you're overstepping
i try and i try and i don't always
achieve it like don't get me wrong i get
pissed off at stuff all the time online
but like
generally i try and assume that that's
where it's coming from it's
probably coming from that and if it's
not what was lost by making that
assumption right
i that is a that again i find that
a far more um gracious viewpoint than i
think that i have
i'm finding my viewpoint to be a little
bit more um
cynical and skeptical than i than i
really want it to be so i appreciate you
pointing that out you're absolutely true
um i i think that some people are like
that's not at all how i meant it oh my
god
i was just saying hey i i went to um
ucla or berkeley music school of music
and and i i majored in audio engineers
well you know if you didn't know this
mike's audio sucks your audio sucks
yeah you know what maybe you're someone
who who feels that's a helpful thing to
say
you know maybe you're not listening to
communication to moderate
the tone oh english second language is
definitely a thing people can be
accidentally pretty drunk in texas
there's that but even even that like
colloquially i dated a girl whose family
was from chicago and the way that they
and they were
a a greek family that english is a
second language oh greg okay i was going
to say like chicago they were from
chicago but like
people i come from the south pizzas
they're like weird
everybody in texas i think that the uh
the english are very similar in this
respect too it's like they'll
absolutely kill you with kindness you
know and the south bless your heart
is not a good thing to say to somebody
bless your heart means he's so stupid
really so oh bless you all just remember
every single time yeah he just tripped
over his own faith bless his heart
um but i think that the dating her i
would listen to the way that her she
talked to her sisters and she talked to
her mom and i was like
you got are you guys okay like you you
look she's like what are you talking
about this is the way that we talk
and so i think that there's some people
i forget that all
not all people communicate the way that
i'm trying to communicate mike exactly
your point
so i think that when people are trying
to back seat
uh you know guide you or or tell you hey
your audio sucks you should do this
i i you're right it's it stands to
reason that it's
just as plausible that they're truly
trying to be helpful
they're watching the show they get us
nobody's backseating us for the record
they said austin's quiet but i don't
feel like that's backseat
that to me feels like just an
observation someone just absolutely like
as a person he's quiet or his audio
level
yeah austin doesn't talk enough it's my
one complaint about playwatch listen
it's just
austin bailey gets away from from your
mouth to
all of my childhood teacher's ears
what do you like as a kid austin this no
beard
exactly the same smaller keyboard
i did have a smaller keyboard actually
i i wrote everything i wrote everything
on a little 44
key until not that long ago until it
broke and i finally was like okay i
guess i got to get a real piano but uh
the same way with shoes by the way
really little shoes
no just like i guess they broke up half
my size
i want my shoes to look like uh tom
hanks's from castaway
you know on the island for several years
just hewn together from falling from
perfect choice but i respect it it's
like the toilet
yeah yeah which is broken again really
what
update did it did
please now
bringing us toilet gate 2021. very good
it's really just a continuation of
toilet gate 2020 and 2019. so did you
re-break it
is it did you have a particularly
aggressive journey
okay no it's just you know this was a
commercial space for a long time before
i came in and
i inherited faulty hardware
um but um either
you have the urine of the xenophobe and
you're able to know that xenophobes
i love i can picture i picture these
these guys down at the border like stay
out of my country it goes to
because you're in the zetaphobe it's
touching it
morph
[Laughter]
um all right i'm gonna intro the show
here hello everyone welcome to play
watch listen
my name is alana pierce that is austin
wintry that
is troye baker and that is mike pitholm
we all work
in the video game industry um i really
should have prepared this question ahead
of time
but did any of you watch mortal kombat
no i haven't i want you really badly
okay it's fine troy nobody has seen it
which is sort of what i
expected is that true apparently i have
listen all i'm going to say is just a
shout out to sub-zero that's all i'm
going to say
you're the only one with serial number
he's played by an actor i really enjoy
warrior no warrior is amazing you have
to watch warrior
it's if he had come out 10 years ago it
would be like up there with the sopranos
it's
it's awesome warrior is great sub-zero
is one of the guys
he's really really good he's in the
warriors way is not
i don't know what that is you ever see
that movie no i did
my god how about the warriors no you
seen that
oh yes
oh what was i gonna ask him oh did
anyone end up seeing godzilla versus
kong
no i watched it what's it like
it's very silly
do you what's your stance on like the
movies preceding it like where are you
coming at it from in terms of like
do you like the franchise do you not
like the franchise like i mean it's kind
of all over the place
they it really feels like each one of
them is kind of a soft reboot
uh this one is the least in that
category because it seems to
it seems to have sort of knowingly built
on skull island and
king of the monsters more conscientious
like it's more aware of the prior movies
than the other ones which all feel
like they've made they i know this isn't
accurate and it's an unfair
characterization but they always
felt like they made the film and then
they were looking at a 97 percent
finished cutting
we should really find a way to kind of
connect this to the other films somehow
like it doesn't feel it's so different
you know
we're very spoiled by the mcu
having this surprising amount of aerial
view of every massive plan
and yeah it's always shocking um
when you think about just how far ahead
they must be working
relative to their release schedule and
this doesn't feel like that and yet it
kind of wants to play in that
sandbox a little it kind of feels but as
a pure popcorn experience you know
it's very pretty colors and loud noises
that's pretty much
what you're saying great underrated it
was like very neon
tokyo vibes it was that was cool i feel
like i'm sorry go ahead
i'm just gonna say the film doesn't make
sense like for some reason in the middle
of the earth there's a sun
but see this is there's a lot of light
for the core of the earth
this doesn't come with the territory
with those movies like you don't get
into those movies for like scientific
i i feel like speaking i i'm moving into
this like pretentious phase where i'm
like i'm i'm
moving soon how about settling into
settling into that little bit more
making
no i i just i i don't necessarily want
to be this way
there's this great study there's a
doctor from i don't know some smart
school
and he talked about how as we when we're
from our youth until about our 40s we
have
this uh fluid intelligence that is able
to
um construct more abstractly and that's
where our imagination comes from
and then as we get older there's a
there's a real star or
steep drop off street flow if they have
the flag a gutting could do the flights
uh that moves more into a crystalline
intelligence which is
more about uh logical linear thinking
you're able to tell stories better
um and you're a little bit more
reminiscent you know that's why
grandparents love to tell stories when
they're growing up
so i i i guess i once i heard that
either i'm just
um relating to that or or whatever but i
look at a movie
first of all if there's anything more
than an hour right now that's a luxury
that that's what planes were for for me
it was like i got 10 and a half hours
let's go there's not a movie that i i
watch the assassin's creed movie
that and usually movies is where i would
watch these kinds of
like the movies that i if i didn't go
see them in the theater i wasn't gonna
there's a million other things i would
rather pull up on netflix so
you know in the in the the before times
was on planes pretty constantly this was
the catch up this was the yeah
oh i never saw the latest you know
transformers but but now i'm
i'm literally stuck in a chair so
now is the time to watch that film and i
would want to go to
the actual movie theater with my friends
and go sit and watch something that is
spectacle
but to for some reason viewing it on the
same screen like we're still going
through west ring right now season three
it's still just as good oh yeah that's
good for them
the yeah well the
first episode of season three which is
you can tell what they did was like
let's pause
because it aired october 3rd 2001.
and so you could tell they shot it out
of sequence and they were like we're
gonna do a bottle episode
but they never reference 911
but they talk around it and it's [ __ ]
beautiful um but i go to that and it's
like let's watch
cg monsters eat each other and i'm like
i don't i i want to enjoy that and i'm
not disparaging that at all
i don't think it's stupid i just i was
the kid that grew up with the og
right so i remember the original mothra
movies
and it was fun and there's a bit of
nostalgia but
that's not that they're it's darker and
grittier and more realistic and
everything i'm like
no i would just rather i watched war
games last night
falling i was falling asleep i love the
[ __ ] out of that movie
but i don't want a remake of war games
you know what i mean i want to watch war
games
so i don't know maybe it's just me
remakes are a very interesting
one that i generally don't want remakes
of most things unless the tech means
that i can't
like experience them anymore for
whatever reason final fantasy
did you watch i still play final fantasy
9. like are we talking movies or games
i mean is there a delineation i i feel
like i generally would probably
just continue to experience the thing
than to have the thing be remade just
make something new instead
i generally agree i do think that that
um there's
i just wanted to differentiate that
since you brought up final fantasy
because that's such a rare example of a
remit like
how often are remakes just top to bottom
total reconstructions
oh yeah that final fantasy 7 is kind of
the only one i could think of
whereas literally also kind of a
different storyline so they're doing
like a whole other thing
with that which i think is actually very
cool because of the unique approach but
like
does that mean they should have called
it something different
final fantasy 7 no because i think
probably
they do that with final fantasy yeah
they they read dream drop distance
4.2.1 or whatever no i think that um
the name of of the final fantasy
remake because i don't feel like remakes
are often
called on the box remake like i don't
feel like i see that
super often and then you're right often
they don't call attention to it whereas
final fantasy does but that's because
it's narratively
because it's the idea of remaking yes so
i think that them calling it that is
actually when you realized why they
actually called it that is a cool moment
so i think i like that being the title
whereas i feel like if you look usually
like even remasters i don't know that
they often say remaster like they'll
they'll go with like
darksiders as the warmasted they'll like
go with some like stupid
terrible words or the something edition
right yeah legendary edition
why would that be like why would why do
they not often call things remake or
remaster
i guess i might guess i don't know the
answer but i
assume it's a marketing thing like if
you what what's more exciting
you know this game diabolical
best ever edition or this game just a
remake like it just it doesn't
remake sounds like a rehash or a re-run
it's kind of a boring
thing that would be my guess i wouldn't
call something a remake i'd always give
it a different
you know it seems negative someone in
chat just mentioned resident evil 2
but that is actually just called
resident evil 2 they didn't call it
resident evil 2 remake that's what we
call it but the official title of that
game is not remake
well you don't need to either enough
times past everyone no one
you know that spyro game like it was
spyro it's just spyro
you know it's not it doesn't need
necessarily the whereas as we're getting
to this stage now where
um and this has come up a lot on social
media where like remakes are getting
closer to the original game's release
like
it feels like maybe that delineation is
going to become more important
like it's like the spider-man franchise
where they reboot it while the
the body's still warm on the previous
one yeah i mean god of war
in 2018 is still called god of war it's
the same title and that's not even a
remake
yeah i find that we figure it out it's
like modern warfare did the same thing
it's and that's not even attempting to
they just call it a they just
use the name that's market research
that's that's if your game has a number
in the title
then a large portion of your audience
goes well i've not played the last
70 of these i had the same thing i
played mortal kombat 11 this weekend it
was the first small combat i ever played
and there was a part of me that was like
wow i'm gonna go into this missing one
to ten here wait what
it was your first model of combat you've
ever played yeah yeah wait really
i never played anymore well my i was my
mates were all tekken so it just i
wasn't
it was it was
it's contagious um
no there were definitely for for me
growing up the tekken and the virtua
fighter kids you just didn't mess with
them because they were like
it's the difference between someone
plays call of duty and someone plays
rainbow six
or ghost recon you're like yo you're
you're you're on a whole other like
there there's there's a mindset there's
a button masher and there's someone
who's like no i know there's a
difference between knowing like
moves and like the difference between
call of duty and like amma like the
people who play alma 3 still to this day
yeah it's like you're you're buying into
a whole other level
the the level of realism and everything
else you're really there the ghost recon
to me was the one that was always like
no no like i've outfitted my gear
to to spec um those were the virtua
fighters and this i
loved that game so much ghost ghost
recon
lan parties was like oh dude one of my
definitive experiences
just land parties in general kids today
they don't know the joy of just grabbing
an xbox and
putting on or a pc and not putting under
your head we had pcs yeah i remember i
remember my mom came in the room and was
like it looks like you've set up an
office
kind of yeah because it was it was like
four card tables and we all had our
backs into the center and the room was
too small and the pcs
it made it 50 000 degrees in the room so
we're all sweating and
looking just exasperating south park
episode one
basically look it up
i um i we we would actually play
call of duty modern warfare 2
um in the studio where we recorded the
game
in all of the different rooms and
it was too much fun because you would
hear people
and every single studio had like a big
55 inch or 65 inch tv
and so we're all playing there all
connected and we're on
comms together not playing on the comms
that came with xbox
it was dope that way we could actually
team up and be like next level
uh he's over there he's like in uni
we worked out how to run we worked out
that the universities like internal lan
had no security on it so we were playing
so we were playing halo lan
over the internal network of our
university so you could play
people like the other side of campus of
course there was no chat so you had to
like call them on your phone and kind of
sync up but you could run a lan party
like
with people who were like three
buildings over as amazing i guarantee
you really i was really
uni i don't know if that's coming across
that was really i was one of the cool
kids at union yeah yeah
yeah yeah we uh we figured out how to
get
i don't know who actually did it but i
imagine it was like one of the grade 12
kids figured out how to get
counter-strike on every pc at my high
school
and they didn't the teachers couldn't
figure out how to get it off so i don't
know how they did that but it meant that
we could play counter-strike during
lunch
breaks it's just someone figured out how
to get it on every single one and they
didn't know how to remove it it was
absolutely god's work
yeah it was great i think they figured
it out over time but
this was before your precious tick tock
in your
um mike you had a you had a thread that
i thought was very interesting about
model combat well a lot more combat for
rounds for it was
rubbish and stupid and shouldn't have
been allowed no that's a good point one
two or three
wait what was this i could talk about it
i was fine
i so i i missed it so yeah
so so like there's definitely like a
snobbishness in video game
talk especially around writing like we
definitely always talk about like
i think there's a i think what what
there's definitely
snobbishness when we talk about video
game writing there's definitely the same
three aaa games we always talk about and
the same like
indie stuff and i just it was just a
weird experience playing mortal kombat
11 it was genuinely my first small
comeback i knew like
that there was like a scorpion guy and
like a sub-zero
and like a ryden or raiden and like they
were in a tournament that was literally
i knew about the
like literally that was all i knew and i
went into the last eleven
and he's lost right that's fine
genuinely like that story just
grabbed me and like pulled me through it
like um like a marvel movie it reminded
me there's um a youtuber called
i'd go harder it's not my own game but
like
genuinely like how well yeah he's in
more combat 11
which is the funniest thing because i've
sat there playing it and
and your character that you play mortal
kombat 11 single-player campaign
you play two yeah you're the cowboy who
else are you
the cowboy here i'm aaron black and i'm
chinock
i didn't catch that i didn't catch that
so i caught you on the couch
you say the first light you say like one
like you grunt or something like your
character's first appearance is like a
little like
and i was like i turned to kerry uh
while i was playing i was like goddammit
i'm enjoying this story and troy has
shown up to completely break it for me
there was having a good time and a while
troy baker appears
yeah yeah but no i was just impressed by
how much you brought me into it there's
a youtuber called patrick williams i
like who did a video where he took his
parents
who'd never seen like a marvel movie to
see avengers end game and the weird
thing about it was they kind of got it
like they it works as a movie if you
don't know all the stuff wow and i had
the same thing with mortal kombat
whereas like
i get this like i know these characters
and that's hard like and and for me
that's the stuff that i'm really
impressed by because
that's the nuts and bolts storytelling
and like big franchise stuff
that's not as easy as it looks that's
really challenging to kind of bring an
ensemble cast in with like a time travel
plot
and then this and that and get me
through it that was impressive so
i had a good time with it not only that
but also to me with mortal kombat the
thing that impresses me is
the amount of like piss taking that was
done from ed boon
before this was mortal kombat the you
know
pillar of games it was just a very
successful
very controversial you know stand-up
arcade
that they were just trying to keep on
the floors of the arcade because all of
the
fundamentalist christians were trying to
get them pulled because of the amount of
violence that they had on it
and so like all of the toasty and
everything else that was in that were
just like
there's always been this element of camp
to it um
which to me has helped without it it
being cheesy and hokey
um but the the ability to go from 1993
to 2021 oh my
i was born in 93 where are you really
i've done that that's my whole life
my god you basically are mortal kombats
as a person
and to and to be able to tell you apart
from harrison ford or any mortal kombat
combat which one but to go
you you drop off after three with no
more stand-up arcades
you go console only and then
being able to reiterate and basically
not just
reskin the same game but it's the same
mechanics
and you still are fresh you still are
innovative
you still and you also have now the the
you're no longer unfettered you're now
encumbered with lore
and you're like ah [ __ ] we just wrote
this thing about outworld that we were
just trying to get the [ __ ] thing and
now
people are gonna come back to us that's
why like d and d
and wizards of the coast what they've
been able to do it's like
how in the world do you take 40 years of
lore
star wars i was going to say star trek
is perpetually challenged by this
problem of
like how do we how do we navigate the
endless amount of
sort of show bible we have especially
knowing that our fan base
is really really into those specifics
and yeah exactly and
waiting for uh there's a funny scene in
galaxy quest
where um oh god what's his name uh uh
i'm trying a blanket saying justin not
not just in bertha but justin long oh
yeah just as long as character is like
uh did it did it bother you uh when and
finally tim ellen was like it was just
starship that's actually a quote
from uh uh william shatner
where someone gives this long diatribe
he's like i'm curious why you had the
dilithium crystals in this but obviously
you switched to this and the schematics
love that they asked the actors the
stuff for the writers yeah guys
it was a television show yeah exactly
my favorite was the family guy episode
where there where they go to ask the
next generation cast
uh and it's like a dry sponge is a happy
sponge yeah i have a rash on my
leg and i'm curious what's causing it
you take hot showers not showers
dry skin so good um
yeah i actually funny enough i play the
originals
you know one two and three back in the
day and then never touched any mortal
kombat again until 11
and had a kind of similar experience
mike where i dropped right in and was
like
you know this is very soap opera
but in a way that it it knows what it is
and the true sense of soap opera
quite fun uh yeah i i enjoyed i
i think there's not enough respect for
that kind of writing and
that kind of writing is a lot of the
videos history right like
pulpy gets you through the process
makes sense and it can be done well and
it can be done badly but i think often
we're always distracted with the
glittering light of like
oh this game has you know the most photo
real character ever so therefore that
one's got a great story or this game is
the most pretentious hipster indie game
ever and i speak as a potential subsidy
in the
hipster indie game
we go to that one and i think actually
like 99 of the games industry is the
stuff in between
it's like um i remember i know i've met
a couple of people who write for um
eastenders which is so big
one of the biggest soap operas in the uk
and
the amount of crap they get from other
writers for writing soap operas but they
have to write
like each of them i don't i don't think
it's a very big writing team i think
it's like between five and ten people
they have to write like half an hour
of good character drama every week and
that and maintain a standard which has
this massive audience with all dialogue
are those weekly
weekly episode drops because the
standards is for i think it's i think
it's down because of covert but
historically it was like four nights a
week
yeah okay soap operas here like young
and the restless and all that those are
daily drops and i have a friend
anyone can write something kind of the
actors
i have a friend who uh a composer pal of
mine who i
i knew uh in when i was living in new
york and he had worked as like an intern
or something for the music
for the composer that was doing like the
bold and the beautiful or whatever or
you know one of the one of the daytime
soap operas
and he went and visited the se he said
they had like this one building where
most everything was happening if i
remember correctly i i might be wrong
but it was like
they had shooting stages where they
could shoot and then just right around
the corner were editing
and they had in-house you know music
production and it was all obviously
being done
really fast and very heavily like they
would the composer would basically
create a library so they could just drag
and drop stuff
as fast as possible and it wasn't really
being scored
bespoke but uh he told me he visited the
set and was watching them shoot and he's
he's like
you know the writing is obviously very
intentionally campy and the acting hams
it up but he said
those actors deserve so much respect he
said he was sitting there watching
and it was like okay we have five
minutes to get this shot
because it's just the sheer volume of
content that they have to and it's like
you need to be in a you need to be
worked up in a you know you're crying
ready okay we shoot in three seconds
like
these actors just having to shift
emotional gear
like crazy to be able to produce an
hour-long episode
a day it was uh he was he was in such
awe and it made such an impression on me
hearing him talk about it
with no rehearsal by the way yeah
they also have to do if you haven't done
so over troy sorry sorry about this
because they have to be really
watching that's not being watched no
being too emotional
too frequently because then if there's
like a seasonal arc where something
needs to be an emotional peak but
they've done that in the first episode
it just makes the character look crazy
so they also can't like they have to
measure it on a long-term scale of like
how
how much are we going to hold back
throughout how far this is going to go
and i don't know how you do that
for a level mortal kombat games and have
every character have a character arc let
alone a soap opera with an episode
five nights a week i think it was either
james franco or joseph gordon-levin i
can't remember who said i want to do a
soap opera and he left me
whoever it was was like that's one of
the hardest jobs i've ever had to do
because it's like here's eight pages
what tomorrow
yeah after lunch yeah but jesus
and you gotta go and it's it's long days
and they are
i'd like to get another take get the
[ __ ] out of here
you better nail it in the one it's it's
hard at work
hard work so much
yeah you know and it and it fits you
know like you said about the pulpiness
like it
it fits a it there's a there's a market
for it like there's people that that's
exactly what they're looking for from
their narrative and the idea of like
something that's
super introspective and plums the depths
of your soul
and rips your heart out and all that
it's like no i'm not really looking for
that i want to i want to know like
i want to know some some sub-zero
melodrama
and that's perfectly okay with takes
talent
to write that stuff well and to make you
care about the silly man with the ice
powers
takes an enormous amount of talent and
and i think yeah we
we all we all can miss that so i just
wanted to that's what that thread was
i was just impressed why were people mad
at you
i think there's like more i think
there's in the fan base there's like
people who hate that game because they
prefer
another game or like in the franchise or
they feel that's never happened
basically like people it was mainly
people who prefer a different
mortal combat game and therefore i was
wrong to enjoy the one i enjoyed
and then i'm weird i'm just wrong but a
sinner who should die
well and there was a weird conspiracy
theory that i was trying to get a job
another realm oh that's right i love
that no i love that it's like i don't
think i'm a good fit for that studio but
fair play i'm so pretty happy with what
i'm doing
it's going okay so far we'll see how it
goes going back
to your original thing as far as people
offering audio advice
unsolicited you know advice do you feel
that that still applies when someone is
is making a comment like that about what
you
do you feel do you think that they're
just wanting to engage with mike bithell
do you think that they are that there's
a level of respect
that is uh unfortunately not being
expressed because of their inability to
articulate
their argument in a more
like that's the thing i have to remind
myself a lot is anything yeah twitter
can also be a child
right who among us can you imagine if
when we were kids
we had a magic box that let us talk to
like our
idols or people who made stuff we liked
can you imagine the crap we would have
said
i like if i could have like it's just
it's terrifying to me i think you know
so i don't i don't begrudge anyone a
crappy message
i do get i do get messages like that
sometimes that my version of that is
you know like i i've been doing this um
the dice podcast the game maker's
notebook where i'll chat with composer
colleagues
and so you know like i did one with jack
wall who's done a bunch of the call of
duty games he's done all the black ops
games
and um and so you know invariably
there'll be a comment somewhere that's
like austin you should do a call of duty
you know like as if as if it's just like
oh [ __ ] you know what
i haven't thought of that i totally
you're right let me just get like
yeah like and there's there's always
it's always funny and i always assume
it's well intentioned but there's always
a funny kind of
like this is a whole there's a lot to
that sentence that you probably don't
even realize there's a whole
there's a whole process by which these
companies
uh choose these things and sometimes
i've i've been in the ring on these
things and then they went another way
other times they had their heart set on
so like there's a whole dynamic that is
just glossed over and i never i never
assume that it's meant rudely but it is
always
funny sometimes in those cases but it
sometimes does have a little ring of the
like
there's definitely like reality i wish
you i
want to be clear on that like there's
definitely people who get actual abuse
sent their way and that's not what i'm
talking about like
nonsense i get sent like there's real
crap but of course
yeah i think troy i imagine you get it
too but i often get people be like come
to a convention
in this country and i'm like okay
how do i organize that they're like when
are you coming here
uh to your budget how are we gonna make
this happen
i'd love to there have been some like
i i really respect i respect people that
have the
um uh i've i've been
on both sides of that commerce
i have been in front of those that i
venerate
as idols and go hey man i just want to
let you know what your work has meant to
me
or hey i would love to work with you one
day i've been there so anybody that
comes to me that way
i have a level of respect for them i
also understand
as you kind of uh we're expressing that
that's not how it works and it's it's it
would be grace i was like hey why have
you never do you not like
our country do you not like our city
because you've never been here i'm like
no no one's ever invited me but
typically if it's a cool spot i'm gonna
go
yeah i was my last flight that i took
in the before times i was on my way to
kuwait
i had never been and i want to go and i
want to
i want to see this world to me it is
borderline
blasphemous that we have looked in
trillions of miles in every direction
and we have never found a place like
this
get on a plane get in a car and go
see it walk most people don't leave
their own city you should have a
passport we're rounding the corner to
where the world is going to open up
again be ready
go experience other cultures go
experience
be in a place where nobody speaks your
language
and see how you adapt so all of this
earth realm
and then if you get invited to the
nether realm yes or any of the other
realms
you should also go see the subzero man
out world
yeah go see i believe his name is silly
iceman
with the no you silly ice man with no
silly blue man with the ice powers
rewind the tape yeah
no i'm with you troy i think generally
like my stance on conventions and that
one people are always really kind about
i've never had anyone be rude to me
about that um is i will go to literally
any of them
i just have to be able to get the time
off work and the opportunity to go but
i'm never gonna say no to going to a new
city i'm gonna be like hell yeah
do that of course i will there have been
some cities i've gone to i'm like
huh i can now officially
and with an informed opinion say this
city sucks
i've been there and you know it sucks
and you're trying
desperately to get out of it but
that reminds me of a time when i was at
a convention in the in the uh north of
england and then i went down into london
on my way
back home and i stopped by some friends
uh office and they said where were you
and i said i was just in middlesboro and
every one of them looked at me and goes
why yeah
so disparagingly and i was like it was
quite nice it was you know it was
quiet and sort of a factory kind of
reminded me of being in like
you know the outer skirts of pittsburgh
or something you know where it feels
like this was this was probably a big
factory area at one time and now it's
kind of like the shell of that
what was it manchester was the
birthplace of the industrial revolution
is that or is it birmingham
birmingham is where it's kind of like i
think both claim it to be honest
manchester definitely has that i mean
pizza
of industrial revolutions
yeah dude i've got i've got my shirt
with the b when there was when there was
the
the the big boom in manchester
i wore my bee for in solidarity i i have
one one part of the uk
i love manchester i love that that hall
that you guys have in the middle of the
city is
just my favorite one of my favorite
theaters to play in the world it's
beautiful um
but i i have one country left one part
of the uk left that i haven't been to
and
i i've yet to be in wales so hopefully i
get to take that box
soon have you done both north america
and ireland
i'm half welsh i didn't know that sorry
what was that awesome we were also
shocked by the second revelation
of uh this episode of play watch lesson
one mike's never played mortal kombat
two
mike's partly well twist we're doing a
lot of lore in this episode i think
we're building i was curious yourself
pay off a couple of episodes from now
you know it's good
i have a question about the welsh go
ahead and awesome
well i was just i was teasing i was i
was exploring the edges of your claim
about
the uk and i was curious uh if if that
is inclusive of
the entirety of ireland like are you a
northern ireland and
you know ireland ireland i don't know if
you're aware but that's a slightly you
know that's a contentious issue a very
contentious
yes of course but my point is if you say
there's only one country
that i've not been to in the uk i was
curious i was curious
to s explore the nuance of the claim so
the united
kingdom would be england yes yes
so yeah the only one that i haven't been
to is is wales i have a question for a
welshman
i can't be sad
i speak is it inappropriate
like i i remember brilliant i love wife
if your roommate walks into your room
and you're masturbating
but specifically from a welsh problem
my thing the question was uh i used to
always say don't welsh on a bet
yeah and i didn't real but it's it's
it's welch
on a bet but you invented a slur
yeah so i i said that to traveler and he
looked at me as like welch and i was
like
hey daddy needs to look something up
real quick and it was like what is the
etymology of this
of this phrase and there's conflicting
things where it meant
this but it was loosely tied traveler
calling you out like
should you be saying this oh it's
actually father what do you mean you've
misplaced the word it's a bit offensive
dad i was like jesus my son is woke
um i'm trying to figure out
do you know if if that is south park in
this episode
because i don't want to be in wales and
say it's like hey
don't welch on a bet and they're like so
what's this
i've never heard the phrase was that
what does it mean i've never heard it
to not welch on a bet where if you make
a bet or if you uh and you lose you
better pay that bet don't welch on a bet
um it's someone that make good on your
promises okay um
so it's in the same way as like i don't
want to say i got gypped
um you don't want to just like it's not
i don't know what that means either
but no i don't think welch has that i
don't think welch has that origin i
don't think it's a welsh
there's there's definitely ones like
that like going uh going dutch or
like yeah there's lots of in europe
especially like
basically every country has a bunch of
negative terms
and perhaps they assigned other european
countries
they're afraid around europe they move
around so
that's the brilliant thing is based on
history every european country
has a different set of sayings which
reflect their individual historical
relationship
to all the other countries so they're
neighbors it's fascinating
it's like watching eurovision eurovision
is amazing because all the voting in
eurovision
is entirely politically motivated
culturally fast and australia's in there
for some reason we'll take it
um i looked up the definition of welsh
uh
as like a word and according to oxford
uh it's failed to honor welsh is a verb
offensive meaning
fail to honor oh so that is uh that is
uh
yeah so troy didn't just didn't oh wow
that's that's okay i've never heard that
so troy wasn't making an innocent
mistake he is just an [ __ ]
or he invented the definition he said
it's actually true in for yeah it's like
contributor t
baker yeah he edited the auction line
3am he's on there online dictionary is
just
just as integral as i have my latest
round of revisions
the professor and the madman is
basically about you and uh yeah
makes all sense now i would have thought
that like in my head you kept saying
welch like with a ch and i kept thinking
of
vomit but that is more akin to belch
which is then i think still a burp yeah
i think i probably combined the two
just made me think of fable for whatever
reason belch is we're really
demonstrating our collective mastery of
language here today look at us go
all inspired by mortal kombat what a
mastery let me tell you though that film
which i
will still not spoil for you terribly
written except for kano
who hasn't heard there's things that
don't make sense about what happens to
you
isn't he an aussie by the way yeah and
he does a great job
yeah it's like a a good australian
character that is voiced by an actual
aussie i was like very
very happy with kano the uh i'd be
interested to see what you think of the
of the lead troy is performance was very
distracting to me but i've not seen a
lot of i don't spend much time on
twitter these days so i don't know what
the kids are saying about it
look i love the 1995
horror movie when did it come out 94.95
i love it
i love it it's great i i think
christopher lambert is raiden is like
who
is the ancestral god of chinese
you know thunder is like yeah you get
christopher lambert he's like
that to me is just like the goofiest
thing you could possibly do
and then not have him come back and
replace him with
the other dude in in in part two and
they go to outworld and it's great
johnny cage is is is it's just awful but
i love it
so much in the same way that i love war
games but war games is a far better
movie
so you were saying earlier that you
think that as you got older you stopped
being interested in stuff that's silly
if i took that
the right way i just yeah i i and
and i'm fully prepared to to say that
this is a seasonal thing it's just where
i'm at right now it's what i'm
reading um the things that i'm i'm
taking the time
time is is a precious commodity and
we're all
we're all given the same amount of time
we just choose to do different things
with it so it's
i'm never going to say that i have i
don't have enough time because that's
not true i make different choices
because
i have the same amount of day that mike
is given he's just eight hours ahead of
me
um so i i sleep more probably yeah i get
i get seven seven to eight typically i'm
i'm an eight nine guys so
are you you're definitely getting more
hours tonight anyway no no no
that was important like that's the third
fact of the show mike gets roughly eight
tonight i was sleeping
in three episodes all of this is going
to come together
only sleeps nine hours that means i
really hope
here's what i hope it's going to wake up
very well rested in wales as an
establishment
i but it says wales that no one can read
it because it's in wells for people like
what does that [ __ ] say it's like a
subtitle
i'm hoping against hope that the people
at one
up listen to this part or someone sends
it to them
and they go listen as a model as a
matter of
moral principle it is important
that mike appreciate and understand
the foundational origins of this game
and they send him
the stand-up arcade of one two and three
all combined so that you can play it
because ed boon said that three
was his favorite and that was up to
about probably when ten came out so he
considered three
the perfect iteration of mortal kombat
two built upon one
three introduced the run button it was
perfect
that said for giving such a glowing
endorsement
i really really really want for one up
to send me
the stand-up arcade of one two and three
as well so that mike and i can play
online and people get to see me
whoop his ass whoop his ass the standard
the the cabinet can play online did you
just say that well it'd be like a pc in
a box right it'd be like a modern
computer right
yeah well we would we would do a we
would do a a zoom
i don't know don't figure it out don't
don't it's not just
talking austin's pointing out it's the
game itself like
how would the games talk to each other
that's what he's asking there they'll
we'll connect them you're basically just
making sure the other one does that it's
like when you're
seeing it's like it's like journey okay
where you could play against and you
think it's a computer
but really it's a person the whole time
you see
it's mind blown there you go it's i
understand
was the uh uncredited the lead designer
on journey uh
little known fact so it's actually an
anagram
the man who knows about mortal kombat
tell me if this is someone who's real
um they make just this one offhand
reference to someone called eddie tobias
yeah is that an actual character
i know i know ed and tobias but that i
kept being like they said eddie tobias
and the people i was with did not
understand
my excitement about that at all but that
is that someone who exists in that
universe or is that just based on their
names
that's just based on their names okay
yeah i was very excited about it
mentioned it like three times and
everyone else was like
like noob cybot is is boon
and tobias so that's where a noob cybot
came from
it's true i don't have my glasses with
me
please send me the one up i really love
that this is like basically
i have to title this episode something
to do with mortal kombat but we've
actually never talked about the film at
all because i'm the only one who's
saying it mortal kombat and the wealthy
yeah it is i'm gonna have to be like
mortal kombat bracket apology
for moving apologies to the welsh
um well on that note we are pretty much
at an hour here 60 in the can baby
pretty close
yeah thank you all for watching for 60
whole episodes some of you i guess
you know some good ones some terrible
ones in there it's fine there's one guy
in prison that can't figure out how to
change youtube and he's like this is all
i have to watch
it's just can't change youtube it just
auto plays
oh i love it forever he's really getting
into that mike bithell law that he was
really hoping they'd flesh out trying to
get down 60.
the the mike bithell wiki page is being
updated
really well it's san quentin
now that i think is cruel and unusual
though so i suspect it won't last long
comes in jesus christ guys have you just
had this been looping the entire time
oh i was gonna say in the last like
couple of minutes we can do a couple
more minutes if anyone has any questions
uh at all i can i can throw them to the
gentlemen we'll see if we have any
um questions
really i would only say maybe one of
them
is what we will get through but so far
people saying thank you for the show
it's a lot of very positive feedback
someone complained about the audio and i
said it wasn't my fault
if i was i supposed to be recording by
the way i didn't
now we're good it's old never gets old
i never get sold austin real bad
was there was there at least was there a
moment where you thought maybe i was
serious
yeah i definitely thought you were
actually another second 100 that whole
time i was like
not that it matters you know sometimes
we just have audio
by the way i a friend of mine had the
most amazing suggestion yesterday
shout out to yon from tripod we were
talking and i was telling him how if you
ever go back and listen like if
when i send you my audio to edit it if
you listen back the moments where i'm
listening to you guys talk is always the
most uncomfortable
where you kind of hear all the like
and he was like he goes you need to do a
cut
where you eliminate whoever the main
speaker is
so
[Laughter]
i was laughing so hard trying to picture
how uncomfortable
i don't think i could make it through
three like 60 seconds
oh i couldn't i couldn't see the best
super cut would be just a super cut
of when we're about to interrupt
somebody and it's just
my thing is because i'm on bloody
because i'm not across the atlantic
there's like always like a once
half a second delay there is anyway
always interrupting it's really annoying
driving the speed of light i think when
we get to do this uh in person
at some point at some event one day and
we still interrupt each other then we
can't use that excuse anymore
well it's going to be i was thinking
about this the first time we'll have
we'll have mike sit at the end of the
stage
all by himself because of the time
difference it'll work
i'm gonna like probably the first time
we'll be we'll i'll come to la sometime
i imagine
after lockdown lift so we'll probably do
it then right yeah we can make that
happen we can figure that out
yeah can't wait we were all gonna go to
we were all gonna go to wales but
uh yeah we're gonna go to wales and
mike's not there but we were gonna go
uh we gotta wait a minute i have okay go
ahead
from drum master 1498 that i thought was
a good one um but i don't know if i've
ever asked you guys this before what's
the favorite
game you've ever worked on what
that's like choosing your favorite kid
yeah putting you on the spot to drown
i don't think he was asking for that i
it's your favorite experience working on
something
it's for me i can get that one out of
the way um
it's impossible for me to say it's it's
more about
what is my favorite thing about that
experience rather than what is my
favorite experience
um because if i if i can somehow elevate
one thing above the rest
that to me somehow prioritizes it in a
way to where the lesson that i learned
here or the
whatever this this gave me is somehow
better as opposed to
thinking about it literally and laying
it out and
and saying i learned something that was
impactful and important from each
experience
even if it was the bad i love the
richard burton quote even if it's
rubbish be the best rubbish in it
so there's a lot of games that i've done
that are not bad binary don't moon
and it's not a great game but i
learned a lot and i had a blast making
that game being two months in japan
travis and laura and it was incredible
that was that was an incredible
experience so shitty game
awesome experience i think
probably my answer is the most boring
which is i think subsurface circular is
the best thing i've ever
done that's interesting to me that's the
one i'm
i guess i think it's the most true it's
the it's the most kind of true to what i
was trying to do
i guess that's it it's not necessarily
the best game but it's definitely the
one where i feel like i've executed
like the version in your head resembles
the final
uh solitaire overtook it so yes
absolutely six months solitaire was four
so that's insane yeah austin
i my answer answer's kind of like troy's
where i always
remember things based on like how i what
i grew
how i developed as a composer or as a
person like if that project exposed me
to ideas that i hadn't
before and i'm just a better more
well-rounded person as a result of being
part of it because of
either the game itself or the people
involved in just the conversations we
would get into
while working like a good example of
that would be working on this vr title
luna with um
robin hunnicky because we would just
have these really intense conversations
that would go for hours and hours and
hours so she's great
like you know that kind but i mean
obviously journey journey fired on all
cylinders in that way it because it
really
it took me to another level as a
musician like it just pushed me harder
the demands of the game were such that i
i had to kind of
catch up to the quality of the game they
were making and i think i came out of it
better
than i went into it like it was almost
like paid training
um and but the game also i remember when
genova first
told me the pitch for what he wanted the
game to be
i thought i didn't realize i've been
waiting my whole life for someone to
make that game and you're telling me i
get to somehow be part of a thing like
that
and it just was so surreal to me even
just on the premise of what they were
trying to do before they
before they'd you know before one line
of code existed like the thing was
non-existent um but just
for journey what is the short one it was
too two fundamental sort of
points which was uh we want to make a
game
that sort of explicitly goes through the
stages of the hero's journey so that you
can feel that
the transformational um aspects of it
like it's called journey as for obvious
reasons and
and and uh you know all the steps like
it was very
it was very okay well you know here's
the rejection of the call to adventure
et cetera et cetera and it was
so he really wanted to because he said
this is such a universal story i really
want people to
not just be told it but to feel it to
walk through it
to just so that they can feel that
feeling of transcendence
but even more important than that the
second aspect was
i want to make a multiplayer experience
where people actually bond
and they don't look for ways to beat
each other be better than each other
[ __ ] each other up grief each other blah
blah blah blah
he said i want to see if there's a way
to uh i mean the way he phrased it was
i wonder if it's possible to catalyze
something resembling actual
love in an online uh randomly match made
connection with the total stranger just
gave me and i remember
i heard that and i i well that's the
thing i remember saying
that that's the next stage of evolution
and
i don't know how the hell you could hope
to achieve that but good on you and then
it's like here we are
and people are you know within a month
of it launching people
writing things on forums like you know
dear user 752 you changed my life
or whatever and it was like jesus christ
he somehow he and that game company
collectively of course
um it was very much a team effort yeah
did that so it's like i've been lucky
worked on a lot of games that
i love but i can't deny that that one
i'm a different human being
it's not just that i can't imagine my
career if i hadn't worked on that game
because it altered the trajectory of my
career
fundamentally but i i'm a i think about
life differently
because of that game that's awesome
we'll take that
i'm i must bounce oh yeah
i'm 10 minutes late bouncing is required
bouncing thank you all for watching live
the episode will be re-audio mixed and
published
as usual on friday otherwise we will see
you next week